this year brought us hashtag gamergate
Microsoft earning minecraft all of a
sudden and more controversies than you
could shake a wiimote at whether you've
been voicing your opinion on every
buyout and controversy or skipping it
all because you don't really care and
would rather just play video games
here's a quickie lowdown on four of this
year's biggest game industry dramas this
first one on my list relates to two just
episodes that I made not so long ago
which you can check out for yourself I
call it all the games are broken or
delayed or both this year made us stop
believing in the sanctity of a release
date and the assumption that the QA
process in game development actually
works Assassin's Creed unity had missing
phases and flying in pcs Dragon Age is
still affected by a bug that switches
out your voice actor randomly on top of
that halo Master Chief collection and
driveclub
are both launched horrific Lee broken
with multiplayer and server issues and
that's just the tip of the iceberg
clearly something has to give with the
pressure publishers are putting on devs
to push these games out all we're going
to see a 2015 peppered with the same
glitches and multiple month-long delays
next up I have not had a week go by all
year long with this not been some kind
of resolution used to report on in
GameSpot news this year has had a
serious case of resolution gates whether
we wanted to hear about it or not this
year cemented how much a bunch of people
cared about the fact that there is
evidently no graphical parity between
consoles while PC fans sat back grab
their popcorn and enjoyed the show fans
of either the ps4 or Xbox one took to
the console war battlegrounds to discuss
whose console was doing a better job
some of the drama came about due to the
fact that it became obvious the ps4 was
more technically capable than its
Microsoft built adversary Microsoft
responded by giving developers the
option to use the processing power
reserved for the connect and apps to
instead help boost game performance it
was a whole thing it's still a thing and
execs at Ubisoft aren't making things a
whole lot better by suggesting they kept
the resolutions the same for Assassin's
Creed unity on both major consoles to
avoid arguments that statement was
retracted but who's to say it's not
still true
speaking of Ubisoft who are fast
becoming one of 2014's more
controversial and disliked publishers
they had a little trouble making female
characters this year this one started
during e3 of this year when a few of us
were puzzled to see there was no option
to play a female assassin in unities
multiplayer mode creative director Alex
and Marcio called the absence a workload
issue explaining it would take the team
too long to recreate animations and
whatnot a very similar story came about
for the lack of a female playable
character in Far Cry fours co-op mode
former Assassin's Creed 3 animation
director Jonathan Cooper called [ __ ]
on that one saying it would be a day or
two's work to knock up those animations
as the internet went crazy
the women are too hard to animate
hashtag launched cosplay happened and UB
changed their tune explaining that since
everybody actually plays as a
protagonist are know there was no need
to
female avatar all right then the oculus
rift has been our gateway into the VR
gaming revolution which everybody's been
keen for since well every sci-fi flick
ever and in the biggest controversy of
the year Facebook bought it
Facebook buying virtual reality company
oculus VR for two billion caused a huge
drama
earlier this year among a lot of people
for the Kickstarter backers who wanted
to support the independent creators and
not an evil social media giant the
Minecraft create a notch who canceled
the previously announced oculus version
of Minecraft and actually caused Cliff
Bleszinski to call him a pouty kid and
for those of us who don't like the idea
of playing farmville Mafia Wars in 2d
and are afraid of it plaguing the VR
games market realistically farmville
probably won't come to oculus and you
probably won't need to let the device
access your personal Facebook page
nonetheless the buyout taught an
unfortunate lesson to Kickstarter
backers who realized they ultimately
have no say in the products they threw
their money at and some of you became a
little disenchanted with the future of
virtual reality let me know what you
reckon was the biggest drama in video
games this year and if you're into
weighing in on controversies oh you're
not that interested I'll see you next
week